so we all understand that chess is a
very very very difficult game and
there's a very wide and large variety of
strategic plans and positional plans you
get a lot of positions where you don't
know what a good plan is and then you
get those positions where the position
to draw the staple and it's a question
of pieces who's got the more active
pieces you've got a bad piece your
opponent's got a good piece you want to
get rid of his good pieces you want to
get rid of your bad pieces and so forth
and so on
this game was playing in a competition
in Holland called Tilburg Tilburg was a
major event on the chest calendar in the
80s and 90s it was a competition
sponsored by an insurance company and
the top players in the world played in
the previous round I just had this
horrible horrible game that I played
with falling is key of our economy by
the way being the insurance company was
Interpol oaths and Interpol is who
sponsored the tournament and I had
played through the previous round this
horrible game he gets left like I asked
you where I manage to do every
and snatching defeat from the jaws of
victory so this game I was black and I
was really determined I was going to win
this game my opponent it was one of the
highest-rated players in the world at
the time his name was looper and the boy
a [ __ ] from Yugoslavia so he opened
with e4 I was opened up in d6 the French
so you have to understand that my mind
set before the game it was like victory
or else
you never have to win okay against the
French there are many main moves in this
position ePHI the advanced French he can
play the exchanged French which has a
reputation for being a boring draw but
it's not so boring and of course the
tarah 92 is a major move and 93 is
probably the main classical group here
again you have negative sexist einat's
variation or mission before the winner I
was in a mood for a combative I was in a
combative mood I wanted to go for a win
or be fight and I always had a pet
fondness for this move of the Trojans
Queen d7 beckon this is like one of the
ugliest moves you can play I just really
liked it
what's the eye it's such an ugly move of
course in the French defense Black's
main problem is he wants to get rid of
his Bishop on c8 the move Queen d7 seems
to be one of those ridiculous moves that
violates like every opening principle
Under the Sun don't move your queen
early in the game and yet it really is
quite a remarkable woman has
a venomous idea the essence of this move
is that in time black wants to get rid
of his bad Bishop is LightSquared Bishop
which is locked in unfortunately by the
pawns on e6 and d5 he wants to play
decent power by Bishop eight-six so how
does that help blacks maneuver well
there are several things behind the move
Queen d7 the first thing is that there
are some variations actually very
beneficial for black after for example a
move like a three Bishop takes c3 check
B takes c3 sometimes very beneficial the
Queen can come out 284 blocking these
bonds attacking this pawn on C 286
Bishop d7 a deeper move a deeper reason
behind the move Queen d7 and is that
next to the bishops early development my
g7 Commons weak loop around plays Queen
g4 which in those days was considered
the main
and now we understand the reason for 27
is to play at five so the idea from
blacks point of view is he wants to lock
up things on the kingside as quickly as
possible he defends his pawn on g7
thanks to between 97 and f5 so Queen g3
and we get in along with our business b6
so I'm playing for Bishop 86 9 th Street
even today I cannot understand the
movement like we played in this position
really makes no sense so how and why it
appeal to me is anybody's guess the
standard move in this position is simply
Bishop a6 and after Bishop takes k-6
Knight takes a 6 and generally speaking
White has a large variety of ways from
castles a three-night at for Queen d3 so
maybe 3 would provoke my knight to come
back but my knight on a6 is really lousy
anyway so 23 night back but for some
reason by the way the standard move here
is 9 F for black and Castle and put his
keen on b7 if he likes for some strange
reason the mo Queen D 398 was bothering
me and again I just played a really
gross move
a box we can get the smooth question
mark for all kinds of reasons and first
one being and it doesn't help that
Luqman wanted I'm losing a tempo and all
I had it in my mind was that I wanted to
play Bishop a6 and after the trade of
bishops to be able to not be forced to
have to retreat my knight little bow
played 9 f4 and as I was looking at my
position I began to really fret about
this possibility 6 the movie night h5
started taking on a whole dimension of
concern I remember thinking that after
g6 first of all night here followed by
age 4 is a very good idea that the look
that really bothers me was I began to
worry that his bishop was going to come
to that for this mission was going to
come to e5 and I would be in a great
deal of trouble whether that's true or
not I'm not sure but at least at the
board I had a panic reaction against 9.4
I played a further bed I mean this is an
awful game I played between have seven
for some reason in my mind's eye this
move Knight
five was so fearsome I played Queen f7
to pretend again like a second bad move
85 being my first bad move Queen f7 was
a question please yes I keep
disorganizing forces when you put the
Queen in that position a relationship do
other faces oh yeah just organization
it's internal
oh and exactly and again I I had another
possibility which was to get rid of my
bishop which is a strategically very
desirable thank my vision being back and
after a move like 9 h5 I don't have to
weaken anything I could say king of
thing I know it looks bad but because
the position is so blocked and the lines
are all closed he's not really taking
advantage of my bad development at this
moment I mean he may very well take
advantage of things in the near future
but my queen will come here my knight
will come to e7 instead I came
complicated this article moved Queen f7
and played very well he played
a three I took and I play Bishop a sex
tip my bishop and now because of the
possibility of Queen season's check and
we captured with my rope so at this
moment I was feeling pretty okay about
myself and my opponent went into like
the 20 minute think then you know as he
was thinking I'm looking at my position
and I realized that oh my god things are
really white has a host of very good
ideas and in fact I don't even have a
serious move normally in a French
the idea is to attack white center with
the movie c75 but that simply is not
good in this position he's going to tell
you but that's what I was thinking about
what I was going to do for my next move
I was thinking that perhaps I could go
to g5 but this is actually even worse
because after his Knight moves away I
would be obliged to defend my pawn and
then he could play h4 and things are
really really gross if I have to play
the chief or well his Knight could
return to this optimal square h5f for
Bernie I was thinking about h5 as well
so I don't even have the thread to
is lying furthermore I don't even have
the ability to develop this night
because my partner you see seven is
attack so I so I'm starting to worry
about what I'm going to do for a move
and then I found a really really great
plan or white even as I was searching my
god suggestions yes man what do you
think white should do here he has a
tremendous position Queen nine three
this word this is o Queen o that the
boys up
well he can't take this pawn because
sorry that I have to flip the board but
I wanted yourselves to see it from my
perspective into the black perspective
other suggestions for weight concept
okay
what about what about the basic concept
now that you've got you cramped yet want
to cramp you some more how and they've
been the simplest instant kind of way to
do it to forgive the pawn attacks begin
to get the strong pawns in the year to
choose which right what's the best part
I don't know if they can open right
which is the best ponder to have come
after with that one well another way of
looking at the position
from lights perspective is this knife is
superb and he could probably just play a
move like aged for securing the night
okay I would have to do something I'm
not sure what I have to do well we
shouldn't worry about g5 right now
because of the variation responsibly
like 84-84 so I could good and I'm
trying to fight like right
well you're right you're onto the right
concept for white from White's point of
view his bishop is actually quite in
effective thanks to the fact that this
palms are all on dark squares so again
keeping in mind that someday one day
it'll be a miracle
the sun will start to shine and maybe I
would play c5 which is a great move for
life b2b form so what's the idea of
behind the movie to deform in fact it's
twofold the first idea is that you're
stopping them for good any chance for
counter playing based on the loose e5
secondly I don't know what I really
should be doing the idea is to play the
move b5 attacking the rook the rook
would come back and then you play a form
and suddenly this Bishop has a wonderful
wonderful lista it's about to play
Bishop to a3 and that Bishop just carves
into my position mission
the question exactly why not just take
it okay it basically has to do with the
idea of development in this particular
position because all my pieces are
really on their original squares if I
open up the position by capturing it and
actually helping like for example if I
captured his rook did he attack TV
captures and suddenly problem that I
have to deal with how am I going to meet
the new queen eight eight my position is
just getting worse and worse by opening
up the position so I sat there and I was
I was like just wondering what the heck
did I fall out of bed today you know
like what what's going on my mind you
know my positions of wreck I've done
everything wrong and he's thinking
thinking thinking and I'm wondering what
he's thinking about and much to my shock
and surprised he took my now again I
think that the position after v4 is
really close to an overwhelming
advantage for white and when he took
like a ninety six I was really really
relieved because I was thinking that
that
on f4 was a monster okay I recaptured
this night and now he captured my mom so
in this moment I was quite happy okay
he's attacking my night I can't and he's
attacking my pawn on g7 I can't play
Knight to d7 let's check and he takes my
rope
I played knight c6 so he took my pawn
try position looks completely hopeless
he's taken one pond two pawns three
funds more I played queen g6 start back
over
why could he not come no much to my
great surprise my upon it again went
into a deep thing so like I'm just so
disgusted with myself you know like I
wasn't I
I had an alliance I had calculated that
this sacrifice was not good for white
and that it would end in a repetition a
perpetual so here I was really amazed by
Luba thinking because I could imagine
that his thoughts maybe ran to this move
attacking
Brooke I agree playing Brooke here so
now he would have four pawns for a night
but after night here I think the
position is actually terrible just
simply terrible for light for plants for
a knight in general it means that he has
material advantage but this bishop is
totally ineffective first of all my
queen is attacking this pawn on g2
second when I make a move like f4
I'm followed by Queen I don't have
threats by Queenie forecheck and lastly
when I cancel my rook is coming to be
gained and the open files are all on my
favor so everything would be going in my
favor so I couldn't imagine that LUMO
would play TV 7 and I thought that his
only move was to take my Brooke what you
do
yes sir as if you like using it on well
it's his church he take the roof and now
it's my turn so what was it
so what was my intention here so when we
reach this position but the board
previously previously when his knight
was still on f4 I had calculated this
position in my mind and thought that I
had to use the first move that I
analyzed was nine takes d4 because I
that I was afraid that after castles
I would just be unfortunately a rook
down and without much compensation so I
stopped my announce my calculations here
I saw that his next move he would
develop his bishop and he would be doing
great so what my may move had been was
Queen takes g2 attacking his rook what I
had calculated in my mind's eye was rook
f1 because otherwise they take this real
good chance now Knight takes d4
exactly but this was this was the
repetition I expected
Bishop III now I could play tags King D
2 and take his rook but I thought that
this was even stronger I thought this
check King comes here and then I thought
Queen here so in this position and
threatening mate in two I am threatening
Queen C 4 check King be one Queen takes
worth named or queen C 4 check King
takes F 3
discover check ok so sorry
so Queen takes G to look at 190
the problem is this Queen on g2 defends
the night and he would capture my night
would check so what I had analyzed was
check King here Queen here with that
devastating threat of Maidan - as well
as other night moves would double check
he would play King I would play queen g2
he would play kini - and the game would
be a draw by repetition okay so you know
discussed it with me you know discussed
it with the outcome of the opening I
thought for myself well okay just make a
draw and you know like and then
tomorrow's another day kind of thing
my hand started going to wards that g2
pawn and I began to smell a rat
this is kind of like a sixth sense that
you develop over a time with experience
that Lubow had taken a long time in
capturing my rook and for certain he
would have seen baleen takes g2 so I
started to think well is there something
in the position that's good for him
after Queen takes you to after Queen
there is another moon why he doesn't
move his rook on each one what have you
played Bishop III now I take his rook
with check he moves his King I get
another free Brook I take the second
room but let's see what happens
thereafter check if I move my king check
oh my goodness King check oh my goodness
King check and look what happens at the
end of the whole series of captures I
end up an exchange ahead but his pawn
when he moves his pawn here his bishop
would go and check in this pond I be
obviously lost her vision oh wait a
minute I don't have to take a second
rook of course not of course I shouldn't
chase his neck and rook so we got this
position and I said calm down you asked
for condoms
in this position I'll take his pawn
he'll play Bishop III I'll take one rook
very happily he'll move his King then
I'll come back and I'll just defend and
now I have an extra piece I have threats
such as f4 and it's okay I was really
happy I saw the move Bishop III and I
began again to reach towards the g-tube
home and again till I smelled a rat
something is wrong
lubos seem too pleased with himself -
please give himself or is that we would
say - please for his own good so Queen
takes g2 so can somebody suggest a
movement not rook f1 because that was
the repetition and not Bishop III what
else could I do
Bishop before Bishop g'bye exactly
Bishop g5 so whoa
what kind of glue is that well first of
all if I take the room this time there's
no coming back
I can take that second rook but then we
get that variation we saw where he'll
have Bishop versus rook and if I take
his Bishop with my queen
he plays King f1 and there's no way I
can defend against rook g1 and my night
on g8 is lost I would be losing I was so
happy so finally and at last I could put
aside queen turns g - I didn't have to
think about Queen anymore and I was very
very happy about that
okay like okay I can put that to rest so
now I need a new plan right in 97 with
the idea of perhaps of taking his part
also trapped in his queen okay yes sir
well Knight takes e5 he takes with the
queen the midnight takes d4 I saw
castles and that's where I had stopped
so in this was in this position nineteen
I considered my main move my main move
was H fun so what's the idea of age five
this was my main variation and I'll
start to make sense in a moment h 5 h 4
rook to a 7 gotcha
now I am trapping is Queen so what was
the reason for h4 rook here
so his idea if I attack his queen but my
crook he's going to attack my queen with
this room so we're going to play f4
okay I will he will be forced to taste
from that floor and now I'd lost my ass
I trap this quick he attacks my queen 92
and my queen can take comes up yeah the
boards flip and the problem is this
night I G 8th is hanging so in this
position I started having a thought I
started thinking well first of all I can
come to hack him his queen is trap
protecting this night he has no choice
he must play Brooke g3 I have checked he
has rookie 3 and I can make a draw with
this move h5 as a force drum remember
what I said at the start I was Anna and
I wanted to win this game so bad that I
started thinking well maybe I could take
his rook I will take his rough he would
take my queen I would take his queen
so isn't this wonderful I'm a piece
ahead
okay but then I saw some c4
I saw this move c4 and I thought that if
I take his pawns would run me over like
an avalanche so I would have to play
Knight here he would castle and now I
had a new problem my new problem is I
can't stop the movie form and those
pawns just keep coming one after another
so I thought the back position even
though I'm a piece up he has so many
pawns for his piece I would be losing
where I would be partly I would be worse
so in this position
like I said and this position
h5 was my main move and after age five
age four rook rook age three rook f7
rook age three bath form Bishop takes
that for Brooking so and that's how we
get into that repetition okay so far so
good
so I felt so great the Queen takes g2
was not my agenda my menu items of of
calculation h5 I've got a draw
now that I know I've got a draw let's
play for the win okay and the way I
think is no matter how and where or why
how ridiculous my pieces maybe I tried
to find a variation where they're
actually well placed okay now let's take
a look at that rook on a sex it's
probably welcome history because looking
Brooks ooh that receipt plane it's it's
it's clearly a complete misfortune that
the rook ever landed up on a six like
that like somebody threw the pieces in
the air the looks landed on a six and
now I've got to find a reason why the
rook is well placed and then with
castles in for yeah it's about a cooler
bondage if you've ever hunted so at last
I found a reason that just to fight my
rook on a six and again by my movie was
such that I wanted to play for the win
so I played the move 98 so now check
this one out with Knight f7 his Queen's
trapped
completely trend but he let's say he
plays the movie
six to give his queen an escape square
what would be my name
b5 b5 huh this rook that's absolutely
ridiculous suddenly is perfectly placed
I'm going to play rook takes c6 with a
check followed by Knight f7 winning the
game so he cannot play the move
b6 he played what I considered the only
move in the position for him again
keeping in mind that 9 f7 is segregating
his Queen and the game he has only one
little he played
okay so after Bishop h6 which I expected
I have calculated this move by
calculated 9 f7 Queen g7 Knight takes h6
Queen takes pawn takes c4 exclamation
mark he has to use his pawns and get
them moving before my Knights can set up
an effective blockade and after DJC for
at 4
I didn't like my position because I felt
that after he plays dude d5 the two
connectors passed pawns in the center he
would stand better so of course I
expected the move Bishop h6 and I was
ready for it or at least I thought he
played Bishop h6 and I played what I
thought was my star move is upon Caesar
oh thank you so much
I played what I thought was my star move
b5 so in the first place and those
variations where he was playing c4 and
getting a passed pawn death cut out
secondly this rook I now had anticipated
Queen coming to g7 I wanted to take his
Knight and now I thought this was very
clever of me that my rook can come
across the board attacking his
my next move would be move like 96
attacking this pawn blockading and then
my further moves would include f5 and
9f5
I find that for a night of fight and I
like my position so this is why I played
as I did I played b5 now my opponent
played of moves that I absolutely have
not considered whatsoever it never even
entered my consciousness can somebody
give a guess as to what why should play
he has moves like he can't cancel long
because then I could take with a check
right he could castle short night f7
queen and then we get that variation we
just looked at
that's a little bit different of course
but similar variation when it is Castle
kingside
to think yeah that Castle well but
inside Castle Knight at 7:27 Knight
takes and it's at a similar position to
the one we just looked at he played a
move I never considered he played Bishop
g7 why that move completely escaped my
consciousness works well if that gives
you is there's a lot of variations where
you scrape isn't yeah well exactly
well even more more substantially I'm
always looking to extend my pieces to to
give them as much scope as breed as much
breathing room as they as I possibly can
and when this move was played I
understood that in my consciousness this
just this move just buried the Queen
unfortunately the group is extremely
strong because it fit thanks my knight
and I suddenly realized that after I
played my only move King at seven in
disgust to defend it for the night that
my king is actually
on the square that was the intended
square for my night so now I understood
after King f7 that I was lost I was back
to G is being lost
he played Bishop f6 and really I didn't
know I think I definitely just wanted to
resign at this point and I instead I
played 96 and just thought well my
situation is hopeless
I mean I'm material down palms down
exchange down my whole concept was blown
I could have forced the draw by
repetition which is what I wanted to do
and now my king is ugly everything is
ugly with the world is is a horrible
horrible place to find a hole to crawl
into
why is he thinking so as he's thinking
and I stopped cursing myself it actually
started looking at my possibilities
suddenly things didn't seem so bleak
like imagine that I was given three
moves for free I would fight rook c6
rook c8 97 and his queen strap okay this
Queens so hey maybe I shouldn't resign
maybe you know there's something to play
for after all rook c6 rook c9
seven and I win and what could he do the
positions all blocked up it's not clear
at all that he can stop that threat
well my opponent played a move I didn't
consider he played h4 recall that I had
looked at it before but especially in
this position it didn't make sense to me
because if he tries to bring his room to
g3 to save his Queen I have the move at
form
I played rook c6 and once more a very
big surprise
he played h5 now I wanted it I didn't
want to take this pawn on g2 because I
didn't want to lose this pawn on age six
and really really on age seven and
release as Queen I played Queen age
things very happy about this okay rook
c8 97 resigns that's my dream so what
did blue go play
so he was worried about things like
Knight takes d4 perhaps he was worried
about I don't care what he was worried
about now he can resign well he can play
Bishop here but I if his bishop goes to
g7
my knight would capture it he should be
locked in and he's blocked in still and
he hasn't rescue to this Queen and my
next move is going to be Knight to e7
baby could I use Julian imagine you're
like man you know their Queen your
Queens trapped you get you you haven't
connected your roots 97 you've gotta
just resign
you could try t4 okay g-force a good try
and then I would just take it and then
there's no for the good
halation okay just move I didn't see
either so no change money ourselves
recognize that his Queens getting
trapped and then I understood that if I
played the move Knight d7 he has to move
Bishop to g5 giving his queen the square
f6 and if I take his bishop he would
take my pawn with a check I wouldn't
have to trade Queens and we'd be in the
situation where I'd have two nights but
he'd have four extra pump needs to them
which instruct me as a little bit too
many there one of them already passed so
in this position after he played the
moon f4 I said okay he's going to play
Bishop g5 not a problem not a problem
take it easy
Oh take the spot so my idea once more is
to play 97 trapping his Queen and
winning back the palm so now can you
guess what blue boat
Queen g7 I trade and I take your bishop
and don't forget this pawn it's actually
hanging as well in some variations I
mean yes you can play the move g2 g3 but
my knight would then just come back and
you'd be in the same predicament this
before that even worse even worse now
that I've captured this F pawn is
missing there's even ideas of Queen III
check
in this position Luba made a remarkable
move Castle and I go what on earth are
you doing
don't you know I'm going to play 97 and
trap your queen but now notice that the
rook attacks by night so that if I play
97 he plays Queen check Queen takes
Queen takes Bishop takes mite he's
managed to trade off Queens and my
denied is under attack and then Bishop
has asked where's that it can retreat
smooth an exchange down and losing so in
this position whoops
I beg your pardon I played dreaming of
the possibility that if he moves to the
h-file its mate in one place King here
I played my back she played King back I
play check we play King back and night
here and now I expected that the king
was going to end
in a draw after all the fireworks and
everything else yes no after he played
the move Bishop g7 in my face went all
red and i realized i blundered a
horrible move I thought I was lost
getting a drop from a lost position
would have made me happy indeed so at
this point expecting the draw with King
G want he surprised me by playing one
maybe I could just check here and play
97 king of three is a very interesting
move I think I would just retreat my
night with the same ideas as before as
we've seen the Knights defender Queen g7
one right way little release oh he
played a remarkable rule it's like g4
don't you understand my plight mat d7
and trapping your queen you don't seem
to get it now I realized that if I play
ninety seven he has the move
I can't take this Patrick wait he's
travelling my queen
I've been Tikrit and I've been dreaming
of trapping his queen chance I've
trapped in my queen
so f GG for I took it's remarkable
gee one look cheap one doesn't help this
cause I'm afraid I do have 9 check and
90s I see that's a tricky move you plan
to trade but I think 9 age 3 checklist
is the problem how many of you saw this
movie now if I go check he moves his
King check check this is like in those
commercials where he secretly of a
jacket jet
so I don't have time to trap this Queen
my Queens attack I took he played King
three
which is compensation she's got a gain
compensation well if I go tonight at age
six and he will take my pawn with check
my time his next move I'm not sure where
I'll take mine oh my goodness
oh my goodness so in this position
oops I tried my final desperate
desperate try I went night here so I was
pleading with him now take my ruler hi
Brooke
so like if he takes my rook I hit play
Knight e4 Shak followed by Queen h4
check and I would actually be winning I
believe instead he took at night sad to
say I took his queen
and the simple finish to the game rook
takes that form is enough and I resigned
I know but when I was winning why would
I offer drugs so this was a wild and
crazy game but it also was the shortest
post-mortem I've ever had and he came
after the game Lobos it's me Molly yo yo
yo yo
he played so terrible in the open he
said my combination night 66 was
completely stupid if I get played b2 b4
b5 a form Bishop a3 you're strategically
crushed I know they said after queen g6
Queen takes h8 I had a wonderful trap
for you if you take my play Bishop g5 he
said but you know this combination it's
so bad if you had played H 5 H 4 rook 87
rook H 3 F 4 you just could make a
forced perpetual first repetition of
make a draw he said when you played the
move 98 this is my god I thought I was
losing you know bishop but then every
single move was forced f4 and a castle
the c3 h4 h4 h5 c 3 f4 castles g4 Bishop
g5 every single note and you have no
choice and we played and I want but one
of the things that I did find very very
amusing about this game and what
planning was all about was that even in
the most
patek positions where I'd miss plane
completely the entire opening my rook on
a6 was completely senseless I was
discovering or at least trying to find
flying such as 98 at night f7 which
justified my poor complete peace
placement and it didn't work out this
time but lots of fun lots and lots of
other occasions and has worked